- He was a philosopher, self-help author
and motivational speaker.
His first book, Your Erroneous Zones,
is one of the best
selling books of all time.
His message resonated with many
in the new thought movement and beyond.
He's Wayne Dyer and here's my take
on his Top 10 Rules to
Success, Volume Two.
Rule number three is my personal favorite.
And I'd love to know which
one you guys like the best.
And as always as you're watching,
if you hear something that
really resonates with you
please leave it in the comments below,
put quotes around it so other people
can be inspired as well.
And when you write it down,
it's much more likely to
stick with you as well,
Enjoy.
(upbeat instrumental music)
- Creative visualization is
what we're talking about here.
You, the imagery or
the image that you have
of anything in your life is
really like mental behavior,
it's like going out and practicing.
If you go out and practice
with a basketball,
shooting free-throws over and over again,
that's physical practice.
Imagery is mental practice,
it's mental behavior.
When you have an image that
you can succeed at something,
when you have an image that you can do it,
rather than you can't do it.
When you get into your car
and you have an image
that you're going to find a parking place,
rather than there'll be no place to park,
so you're not looking
for no place to park.
You will start acting on
the image that you have,
very much like you will start acting
on the practice that you have
when you're shooting baskets
or when you're hitting a forehand
or working on your soup or
anything else that you're doing.
The telling moment of my life
occurred on the 30th of August, 1974
when I went to my father's grave,
after finding out he had
been dead for 10 years.
And I went there with
a different intention
on what I was going to do on his grave.
I was so filled with rage and anger
and hatred toward this man.
But rather than do what
I had gone there to do,
something, some invisible,
divine, organizing intelligence,
that moves the planets
and grows your fingernails
and beats your heart
that commander in the command center
to which you are always connected,
your, I am presence, if you will
called me back to his grave
after I cursed him for two
hours on that Friday afternoon.
And I stood there and I
said from this moment on
I send you love.
Who am I,
who am I to judge you?
You did what you knew how to do,
given the conditions of your life.
And when I left that grave site
I was a completely changed man.
Alcohol hasn't touched
my lips since that day.
I walked away from it.
I got myself into the
best shape of my life.
I began running and
relationships began to change.
The right people, the right
woman came into my life,
my children began to appear
because when you advance confidently
in the direction of your own dreams
and endeavor to live the
life which you have imagined
you will meet with a success
unexpected in common hours.
Everything about my life changed.
My writing took on a
whole different flavor.
Before I was stuck,
I checked into a motel
room, The Spindrift Motel,
on A1A in Fort Lauderdale, Florida.
Then I wrote a book that today
has over 100 million copies
in print in 47 languages
called Your Erroneous Zones.
It came because the rage was gone.
Mark Twain once said that forgiveness
is the fragrance
that the violet sheds
on the heal that has crushed it.
That's divine love.
My friend Byron Katie says that
to believe that you
need what you don't have
is the definition of insanity.
To believe that you
need what you don't have
because you're already here,
so you've already proven
that you don't need it.
So to go around believing that
I can't be happy, fulfilled,
you know whatever it is,
unless I get this stuff
that I don't already have
it's a complete and total illusion,
it's a thought that isn't even true,
there's no truth to it whatsoever,
you don't need anything
and when you get that
the irony is you're no longer,
you're no longer attached,
your total life is just
about living those virtues.
How can I serve, how can I be sincere,
how can I be gentle,
how can I be supportive?
And thinking like that,
and that's how I think
now and because of that
I'm in meaning
and being in meaning,
the times that I was in ambition
you know
is delivering more and
more and more and more
of what I wanted so much then
and now that I'm not attached to it
it's like I can just be like the cat.
You know I can just go about my business
and just let it follow
after me wherever I go.
So what I say to people
who really want to access
the transition from you know,
from ambition to meaning,
if they really want to access it,
is to get your thoughts off of yourself.
I do it on the radio every Monday
when it's like all my questions,
all the questions are about,
why can't I manifest this,
why can't I have that,
this isn't working and so on,
and my response back to them all the time,
over and over again, is take what it is
that you would really like
to attract into your life,
whatever it is, whether
it's wealth, a job,
you know know, money, a
nice watch, a new car,
whatever it is and want it more
for somebody else than
you want it for yourself,
just it more, just think about that
and think about how much
joy it would give you
to be able to put your attention on that
and just keep your thoughts on that,
you know take your
thoughts off of yourself
and start living the four virtues.
Start being sincere,
start being supportive,
you know start having this
reverence for their life
and so on and just shift
off of what's in it for me, you know
and how much am I going to get
and why isn't it here fast enough
and why is theirs shinier than mine?
And you know and so on.
Off of that and begin to project that
and do that, I don't care
whether you're a school teacher,
I don't care if you're a dental hygienist,
or if you're a carpenter
or you know whatever it is
out there that you are doing.
If you can take your attention,
if you want the door to open,
if you want the door to open to meaning
then the only way that
door is going to open
is if you understand that you
have to leave your attachment
to this grossly world
of the material things
and what's in it for me
and how much am I getting?
And shift your energy, your
thoughts onto how may I offer,
how may I serve?
And I just di a public television special,
another public television special,
and an hour-and-a-half
before the show to start
I was in like one of these
attacks again, in the neck,
and I was just like you know,
how am I going to get
through this thing and so on?
And I said a prayer, my wife was there,
two of my girls were
there, we were in the room,
I had my arms around them and I said,
"If I'm supposed to endure this pain,"
"for whatever reason that
I don't even understand yet
"I'm willing to do it,
"but could I please just
have the next couple of hours
"so that I could at least
get through this experience?"
and it just dissolved, I was able,
you were there, you were in the audience.
And I was able to go out there and do it
and then the pain returned the next day
and I went right back to that state
and I still do it now and
I can feel it even now
as we're talking about
it a little bit here
and instead of cursing it,
instead of being angry at it,
I accept it as my
dharma, this is you know,
whatever it is that I
have to learn from it,
generally speaking every
difficulty I've had in my life,
getting divorced, literally being
someone who is addicted
to substances, including alcohol.
Letting go of you know
those kinds of beliefs
that those are terrible things
that I should be ashamed of,
they've been amongst my greatest teachers
and this pain is just
another one of those things
and generally speaking I now
can go out and help people
who live in chronic pain
and you do a lot of this
with your training.
You know I've seen you do it on stage,
you know with people,
in fact when we were out in Australia,
that one women, what was it?
She couldn't even?
- Well there was one lady
with a frozen shoulder.
- Right.
- Couldn't move here arm.
- Hadn't been able to
move her arm in years.
- In a year and in 20 minutes
she got it up like that.
- Yeah.
So it's like and that comes
from just accepting yourself
and actually instead of cursing the pain
because when you curse the
pain and get angry at it
you just, you get angry at
every cell of your being
goes through that same anger
and what you want to do is
just get to that peaceful
place within yourself
where you say, you know,
when you trust in yourself,
when you trust in yourself
you're really trusting in
the wisdom that created you,
you know.
And the wisdom that
created you is infinite.
And it's formless, so your thoughts
are in that same category,
have thoughts that aligned
with that divine presence.
- Yeah.
- You'll see it going away.
The obscure outlasts the obvious,
try to become a little more obscure,
a little less interfering,
a little less, notice me.
A little less, you know one of
the specific kinds of things
that you can do is just as you're about,
when somebody else is talking,
just as you're about to interject
what you've been thinking
about for the whole time
waiting for them to stop talking,
(audience laughing)
to just stop, to bite your tongue
and say tell me more or
that's very interesting
I have never heard that
point of view before.
Even if they totally, completely disagree
with everything that you stand for
to be willing to listen, to
be able to stop, practice it.
I practiced it when I
did the verses of the Tao
I practiced it every single day
while I was working on that.
Just staying obscure and for
me that's not always so easy
because of just being
recognized wherever I go.
And if I saw someone who
was about to recognize me
I would just put my head down,
I would just walk a little bit
past them, like I'm saying,
right now I just want to be anonymous.
Right now I want to be obscure.
All things are possible
and I always ask an audience
what does that leave out?
You know, that all things are possible
literally means all things are possible.
So whatever it is you'd like
to attract into your life,
whatever it is you'd like to accomplish,
whatever you'd like to do in your life,
if you start from a spiritual place,
a place of all things are possible
if I return and you know
and get to that place.
And then I begin to visualize it.
And then I begin to use my imagination
because everything that we see around us,
everything in this world
was once imagined, every thing.
You know that camera that is there,
the clothes that you're wearing,
the chairs that we're sitting on.
Every thing once had to be imagined.
If you get that, I mean
Einstein's famous observation
was that imagination's more
important than knowledge.
If you can learn how
important your imagination is
and that's where you're
spirit is, in that place
and then once you go to that place
in what it is you'd like
to attract into your life,
you're coming from a spiritual place,
absolutely nothing is impossible.
It was Thomas Troward,
he did some lectures on mental science
way back in the 1907, 1908.
He was from Scotland
He was from Scotland, and one
of the things that he said,
is that the law of flotation
was not discovered by the contemplation
of the sinking of things.
So that like before the
15th and 16th centuries
all of the ships were made out of wood.
Not because iron wasn't available
and steel wasn't available,
but because there was a
belief that wood floated
so therefore you had to make ships
out of things that floated,
that's literally how the,
and then someone came along and said,
that it has absolutely nothing to do
with what things are made out of
it has to do with the amount of water
that is being dispersed.
That's what determines whether
something will float or not.
And I think about that all the time
because it's in the
contemplation of what you desire
that you create what it is that you want
to have for yourself,
it's in your willingness to contemplate it
and nothing more according to Troward
and mental science.
So then I think about the Wright brothers,
you know 100 or so years ago,
and I said the law of
flying was not discovered by
the contemplation of the
staying on the ground of things.
So that these were two people,
like for me to figure out
how to get an airplane to fly
and my limited knowledge of all that
I would probably have contemplated
the staying on the ground of things.
You know like this is what happens,
but there's somebody came along
and contemplated the idea that
if you get enough speed going
and you have the right design
and you get pressure
underneath something like this
that this thing is going
to lift up off the earth,
somebody had to contemplate that idea.
And everybody who contemplated
that it wasn't possible,
that it couldn't work was a part
of why flying didn't take place
because there was no new law discovered
in the early part of the 20th century,
anymore than electricity was
discovered by Thomas Edison
or anyone like that,
I mean the ability to have electricity
has always been there,
somebody has to contemplate.
So it's like in your own personal life
your willingness to contemplate yourself
as a person who is capable
of attracting into your life
what you want,
having the kind of
relationships that you want,
being able to have abundance
where you know scarcity always existed,
all you have to do is begin the process
by being willing to contemplate
the presence of that in your life.
And I've always been a person
that I can remember throughout my life
as someone who could contemplate myself
being able to do things
that most people couldn't
and I can give you a good example.
When my mother got us all back together
and we were living in Detroit,
on the east side of Detroit,
and we got a new television set.
It was a black-and-white, it
was a screen about this big,
it was an Admiral
and we had it in our home and it was like,
oh, black-and-white television, you know,
you remember Uncle Miltie?
There was a guy that was on
TV, his name was Steve Allen,
and he was on The Tonight Show.
I was 11, 12, 13 years
old, I was born in 1940
so it was '51 or '52,
and I used to stay up
every night and watch
The Tonight Show,
even though I had to go
to school the next day
there was just something about that show,
you know and all of the characters,
the Spock Mock, and all the
things that Steve Allen would do
and I would come down when I
would be talking the next day
and I would be telling my
mother and my two brothers,
that when I do The Tonight Show,
this is what I would
say, I wouldn't have said
what Louis Nye said, how he reacted,
I would have said, and I used to do this
and my brothers and my mother would say,
that's just Wayne, he's just nutty,
he thinks he's on The Tonight Show,
(laughing)
he thinks he's going
to do The Tonight Show
and I would go up into my room
in this little tiny
house that we lived in,
a little two bedroom house
that five of us lived in
because my mother remarried
and I would see myself
doing The Tonight Show,
I would just practice it and
Steve Allen became someone
that I was really enamored with.
Well you know fast forward,
I don't know, 30 years or whatever or so,
and I've written a book
Your Erroneous Zones,
The Tonight Show calls and they ask me
if I would like to come on and do it,
so I do my first stint
on The Tonight Show,
I did the show like 37 times
over a period of three or four years
with all these different hosts,
but Johnny Carson was on,
and the first guest on the very first show
when I did the show was Steve Allen.
And it was like something clicked in me
that I had contemplated that as a child
I had always had a knowing
and I can remember sitting
there talking to Johnny
about this thing that, you know,
and Steve Allen was sitting
there right next to me
and we were talking about that kind of.
So by putting my attention on something,
it wasn't some deliberate
thing that I was doing
you know when I was 11 or 12 years old
that was designating
that I was going to be
a person who was going to
be appearing on talk shows
30 years from now, it
was just an awareness,
a willingness to contemplate,
to contemplate myself
in that kind of a place.
And I think the power of contemplation
is the thing that most
people haven't harnessed yet.
And when you harness it in your life
there's absolutely no limit
to what you can attract into your life,
if you absolutely stay
focused on what it is
that you know you're going
to manifest and attract,
you're not going to do it in your time,
you know Jackson Browne
sings a song that says,
let creation reveal its secrets by and by.
I mean you can't push the river,
you can't, it's all done in divine time,
but it will show, it will show.
It will manifest, it will attract itself
and I'm never surprised any longer
about anything that I put my thoughts on
that I can attract it into my life.
I just absolutely know
that law of attraction
and that it absolutely works.
Giving up your personal history.
And I learned it from a
man named Carlos Castaneda
who once said that one day he said,
"I finally realized
that I no longer needed
"a personal history.
"and just like drinking" he said,
"I gave it up and that and only that
"has made all the
difference in the world."
You know the nice thing
about giving up your personal history?
Is that if you don't have a story
you don't have to live up to it.
(audience laughing)
All of us have these bags
of manure that we carry around with us
called our past
and the people who have done things to us
and the events and the circumstances,
all of this stuff that
we use and we bond to
and we bond ourself to
these wounds of our past
and we identify ourself on
the basis of these wounds
and every once in a while we set it down
and we reach in there and we
smear it all over ourselves.
(audience laughing)
And then we wonder why
does my life smell so bad?
I don't understand this?
(audience laughing)
When in fact the now, this moment,
merging yourself into the now
means that you may have
been in a relationship,
I had a woman from Holland
who came over to see me,
whose husband had left her after 25 years,
she had four children
and she just had been
on the verge of suicide.
And she was loosing weight
and she was depressed
and she was taking all
kinds of drugs for it
and she was getting sicker and sicker
because she just couldn't get over it.
And she came to a book
signing that I was doing
at a bookstore down in Florida
and she said, "You've got
to say something to me.
"You've got to say something to me,
"that will help me to get over this."
and I told her this line, I said,
"Give up your personal history,
"merge yourself here,
now into this moment."
and those 25 years are something,
if you want to understand how to do it
think of your past as
oh, this hat"
and this is your past,
now you can't just set
this thing down over here
and walk away from it and
give up your personal history
because you will always have
it there to look back at.
What you do is you pick up your past
and you embrace, you
understand it, you accept it
as I had to go through these
things that I had to go through
in order for me to get to this place today
and the evidence for that is that I did.
You don't need anymore evidence,
you did.
And then you toss it,
you toss it,
you embrace it, and you toss it
and you merge into the now
by giving up your attachment.
And some of you have
heard me use the metaphor
of the wake, Alan Watts
talked about the wake
is not what drives the boat,
the wake is just a trail
that is left behind,
that's all it is
and so is the wake of your life
and the wake doesn't make the boat go
and neither does the wake of your life,
the reason why your life
is going in the direction that it is,
the wake is a trail that is left behind
and it's an illusion to believe
that it is the cause of your suffering
or your struggles or your difficulty,
give it up, let it go,
embrace it, understand it, get
help doing that if you must,
and then move into the now.
Thinking small is what
gets great things done,
Verse 63.
Achieve greatness in little things.
Take on difficulties
while they are still easy.
Do great things while
they are still small.
The sage, the sage, one
of my daughter's names,
does not attempt anything very big
and thus achieves greatness.
Greatness comes from being in the moment,
here, present in the now.
The sage confronts difficulties
but never experiences them.
This is the idea of thinking small
and finally, I'd like to see
you change from this thought.
Change from seeing yourself as separate
to seeing yourself as
connected to everyone
and everything in the universe.
I sat and read an essay
called The Whole Man by Abraham Maslow,
and Maslow was the first
person that I'd ever seen
in the field of psychology who spoke about
we should not be assessing
who human beings are
and what they're capable of
doing based upon what's missing
or what's wrong or what they
can't do or their weaknesses,
we shouldn't study neurology,
neurological disorders,
we shouldn't study how
psychotic people are
or how neurotic they are.
We should look at the greatest achievers
who've ever walked among us,
know that they all came
from the same intelligence
and recognize and help people to find that
within themselves.
And I read this essay I was so taken by it
and he talked about the
qualities or the characteristics
of what he called self-actualizing people.
And he said the number one
quality and characteristic
of these people who live at the apex
of what he called self-actualization
who are way beyond just taking care
of their biological needs,
who are way beyond their social needs,
who are way beyond needing
to be loved and so on,
these are people who
came here with a purpose.
These are people who have a dharma,
these are people who won't let anyone else
determine what it is they're going to be.
He said the number one
quality of these people
is that they are independent
of the good opinion of other people.
They listen to an inner voice.
Yes, our physical body is what it is
but we can make choices about it.
Yes, our spiritual body,
our purpose, our dharma,
what we're here for is also doomed,
but we makes choices,
what are the choices?
You came here to be a great artist,
I did a whole film on
this, it's called The Shift
and this whole idea is that
you came here to be a great artist,
do you pick up a paint brush?
Do you do what van Gogh did
you just go out there and paint
because it's in your soul,
because the second characteristic
of self-actualizing
people according to Maslow
is that they are detached from outcome,
they don't do what they do because
of what result is going to come to them,
because of how much money
they're going to make,
how much prestige they're going to get,
how big their business is going to grow,
that is not what motivates
self-actualized people.
What motivates self-actualizing people is
this is my calling,
I found myself reading the
Bhagavad Gita for the third time
in the last three months,
I just keep reading it over and over,
just like when I did the Tao,
eight years ago when I turned 65,
and couldn't stop it
and the teachers showed up.
The Buddhist proverb is that
when the student is ready
the teachers will appear.
It's not whether there's teachers there,
there's teachers everywhere.
Everything is a teaching,
the question isn't whether
the teachers are there,
the question is how willing are you
to pay attention?
How willing are you to
listen to that inner voice
that no one else can hear?
That little scurvy elephant in there
that says, you're not the boss of me,
you can't tell me what I'm here for.
It takes a kind of fearlessness
because fear is such a
omnipresent force in our lives.
I do what I do because
of the passion I feel,
I am not here because of what
you paid me to be here for.
I am not here because of any need
that I have to sell another book,
I am not here for anything
external to myself.
I am here because I have
a passion within me.
- Thank you guys so much for watching,
I made this video because
Ibby Hadeed asked me to.
Also if you want to nominate someone
for the next Top 10 Video
please check the description
for a link to a video
where you can vote for people
and put it in your suggestions as well.
I'd love to know what'd
you take from this video?
What was the most important lesson
that you learned that blew your mind
that you're going to immediately apply
to your life or your business somehow?
Please leave it down
in the comments below,
I'm super curious to find out.
I also want to give a quick shout-out
to Dave Gardner, from thedavidgardner.com,
Dave thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book,
Your One Word,
taking that picture, sending it in,
I really, really appreciate
your support, man,
and I hope you're enjoying the read.
So thank you guys again, for watching.
I believe in you,
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is,
much love, I'll see you soon.
- The ego is not worth defending.
And we all spend a lot of our time
defending this thing that says,
well you know I am what I do have
and I have to get more things
and if I don't have as much as they do
then they're going to,
and we go through our lives
doing all of this stuff
and what it does is it
brings us to a point where
we not longer have something
or our reputation is gone
or is taken away from
us or somebody steals it
and what happens to us?
Or when we retire or no
longer can do things,
so now people get over a certain age
and they just feel like,
you know I've declined
and so, there's nothing in the DNA
that says you have to
decline ever in your life.
You don't have to decline,
your DNA's over 600,000 years old.
- So then why do we have it though?
Why do we have it?
- We have it because it works,
it works at getting ourselves believing
that we're better than other people
instead of just allowing
ourselves to be free
and that's just like,
the Tao teaches us to un-peel the onion,
un-peel layers to get to,
the essence of the Tao is emptiness,
getting to that place of emptiness,
that's like the supreme place to get to.
Where you're just empty of all of that
and then you're free,
and then guess what?
All of the things that
you wanted so desperately
when you were so ego dominated before
begin to show up in your life
in larger and larger and larger amounts.